the jogan experience it's the first time
in history that you have Commander David
fraver Lieutenant Ryan Graves and then
one whistleblower a guy named David
grush who we we can't validate what he
said because it's all classified
information but Commander fraver at
friends of ours you know Commander favor
he like just told what happened to him
he chased the UFO then you've got Ryan
Graves who his whole Squadron has been
seeing these things you've had both on
your podcast but grush stood up there
and he was very careful with his words
and I want people to know why if you
look at that setting you're going to see
right behind him was a guy named Chuck
Chuck Mulla Chuck Mulla is the Former
Intelligence Community Inspector General
so like the cops of the intelligence
community and he was right behind David
grush who is his client so he's
representing David grush because David
grush put a whistleblower complaint he
put yeah and look at those two handsome
guys right there so there's um yeah this
is the biggest conspiracy photo of all
time can you imagine people seeing this
and being like what are those idiots
doing up there with him but so behind do
with the beard and the glasses in the
back he looks so happy yeah dude UFOs
people think that that guy with a bald
head is James Clapper by the way I got a
bunch of uh yeah it wasn't I about a
bunch of comments that Clapper was
looking at my notes during I got guy I
don't know he's just part of a Ryan's
organization as a but you know here's
the man um this photo is kind of
hilarious because George L Joe George
had um ontological shock when we were in
that room it's like he's sitting there I
mean he's sitting there seeing after all
this time this shit's being said out
loud so so what happened was the seats
were kind of like designated for us
because George and I were supposed to
testify by the way but then common
wisdom says why have these journalist
guys when you can hear directly from the
firsthand people and we agreed but what
we did was we put on Congressional
Record statements and people should read
them if they haven't they're on
Congressional Record I did an assessment
of kind of the estimate of the situation
on UFOs but he he named names and and
and programs but what you're seeing
there is and I kind of had to fight for
this you know is getting his lawyer
behind him should be like an obvious
[__] thing when a guy's going up to
testify under oath in front of Congress
if you believe him he's speaking under
whistleblower protection dude it was
hard to get his lawyer behind him I had
literally had to put the lawyer behind
him so we got the lawyer behind him so
he could lean in and be like careful
Dave careful which he did like a bunch
of times and then there's George looking
all scrunched and everybody's like why
Jeremy over there with no one next to
him I think people are a little afraid
of me cuz you know little bit of a
Maniac sometimes whatever we're there
Dave starts talking they ask him
questions these weren't prescripted or
anything you know we we're talking about
what could be asked for sure but they
weren't prescripted what Dave grush said
and correct me or add to if I get this
wrong Dave grush said I did an
investigation it was my job I was hired
by and this is a guy from from the
national reconnaissance office the
National geospatial Intelligence Agency
like this guy is is he's been in the
intelligence Community a long time and
he sits there under oath and he
says I did an investigation I I
interviewed it was my job to look at uh
over 2,000 special access programs like
black programs and it my job to find out
if any of them had to do with UAP and if
there's any money being hidden like
misappropriated theft and he's like
after interviewing 40
Witnesses I found a ton of [__] that
that supports this and I've in fact he
said I found people who worked on the
craft firsthand and they and they had to
come in or they willingly came in he
called them hostile and non-hostile
Witnesses and he's like so I did that
whole thing the second I did that which
was my job I was given the job reprisals
started happening to me so he smartly
did a whistleblower complaint through
the presidential protection act act 19
or something he went got the head of the
icig the former head of the icig was a
lawyer and he says [__] dude here's what
I know here's what people don't know is
the ICI so the the intelligence
community did their own investigation
into David gush's Witnesses and what he
found they interviewed like 40 plus
under oath and immediately said David
gush's claim is both credible and Urgent
so it's not like just one guy telling
you our intelligence community did a
deep dive investigation into what David
grush told them under oath in the right
secure settings and they're like
credible
urgent so David grush can tell you the
basic things that happened but you know
how he kept saying in the appropriate
environment if you've got clearance we
can do that I'm willing to give you a
list of hostile and non-hostile people
that worked on the craft you know
Biologicals he even said he's like I'll
give that to you today we just got to
get a skiff and we got to make sure that
you have access you have clearance and
he was denied a skiff that
day he's um he's a credible guy he's the
real deal I mean he has uh he had a
career in the Air Force served in
Afghanistan distinguished career then he
goes into the intelligence Community
working for the National geospatial
Intelligence Agency he was assigned by
his boss to be the liaison to the UAP
task force that's what Congress had set
it up to investigate the whole UFO
matter before the current program
existed and that guy who was in charge
of the task force Jay Stratton gave him
a job go find the special access
programs that are hiding UFO stuff
either siphoning millions of dollars or
they've got technology crash retrievals
reverse engineering all the stuff that
we've always heard rumored and he did he
found it um most of the juiciest stuff
that he found he can't say in an
unclassified setting it has to be
because they will get him they will bust
his ass if they can they've already
tried like four times and that's
something offline we'll talk about there
have been attempts to get him silenced
unmuzzled by the way to not do podcasts
or shows and stuff right to get him
muzzled by um people that are trying to
say he's talking outside of his doser
which is like what he's allowed to talk
about so they're they're looking for one
word that he says that's out side of
that like I get asked by by people in
the government has he ever told you the
number of crashes has he ever told you
locations like I'm going to [__]
answer you first of all second of all no
he hasn't because that would be illegal
if it were to be true so he is
authorized to talk about a very limited
number of things that correct and
they're not vouching for their
authenticity doser process which is I
don't know what it stands for but it's
like prepub process he very smartly
because his lawyer is really smart
former icig he's like write you know
write it in what you want to talk about
and see what they come back about what
you can't talk about so they're not
saying what he's saying is true they're
just saying you can talk Within These
parameters I would like to see if what
he's saying is true so we just need that
option so who gives him the authority to
talk about these things no one gives him
the authority he's taking that all on
himself he's a true whistleblower
whether you believe his claims or not
what he's doing is is legal but it is I
mean it's a career killer
right oper says they they go through it
and they make sure that things that are
like highly sensitive are classified
right like you can't say this word or
this program or this name so they kind
of do it as a pre-publication thing
that's the process does that make sense
I wrote a book with uh colum kellerer
and Jim laty about the Dia's UFO program
it took doser 14 months to approve our
manuscript so they take their time but
also when you get push back where people
are trying to ENT trap him or or get
people to say that he said something out
of school
the Doster people are like no he's fine
like he's talked within those parameters
he just has to be careful to not
accidentally say something that is
outside of those parameters and right
now is a very sensitive time for that
you know immediately it's interesting we
met him in Huntsville Alabama at a
conference the SCU conference it's a UFO
event we went down there to interview
somebody else um to get them on camera
and we had been told this guy might
there a guy might introduce himself and
Jeremy was shooting video of me sitting
at the bar at the moment that this guy
walked up and introduced himself so he
had that moment on camera and then we
got to know him a little bit a couple
months later he comes out to Las Vegas
there was a Star Trek convention we were
going to speak at it and he comes out
because he likes Star Trek like
everybody likes Star Trek comes out and
spends two days with us the next day he
flies back Sunday night Monday morning
he reports to work armed security guards
escort him out he was suspended his
clearance was suspended we were worried
oh Christ was was was he seen in our
company and that's what happened but
that was the beginning of his first real
big trial by fire uh they accused him of
a bunch of stuff um and said that they
were going to U fire him and uh
permanently suspend his clearance and
was was he already discussing UFOs at
that time not not with us but he he had
already been investigating it on behalf
of his of the UAP task force and he had
shared information Through The
Whistleblower uh process with the
Inspector General yeah let me just break
it down real simp so here is he gets
this job he's looking at all these
special access programs he's a [__]
brilliant guy he's a physicist by the
way you know like's he's a brilliant guy
in general so he discovers all this [__]
he starts getting reprisals and then the
moment George is talking about I kind of
had heard about him all of a sudden he
comes up to him at this bar where we
were at that's the first time that he
talked to anybody outside of government
now he didn't share anything he
shouldn't but he was kind of coming to
George and then to me to say I'm doing
this whistleblower thing I am concerned
for my safety and just in general for my
career he wanted a journalist or
journalists to know not to report on it
so imagine that we don't even break the
story that we had before anybody right
so what I did cuz I'm his Harpoon I I
did a deep dive into this guy for months
and months and months he actually came
to my home you know met my family like
and I got to know him and I I we we
vetted and vetted okay this guy is who
he says he is he's 100% who he says he
is so we we kind of got that layer of
trust this is not some sham or something
like that but then what happens is what
George is talking about the second trip
so I'm already talking at this uh Star
Trek thing because my my friend growing
up from my Jiu-Jitsu class was Rod
rotenberry so he's like the son of Jean
rotenberry so he's just like dude Jeremy
come talk to a bunch of trekkies about
real UFOs and I'm like cool I'll do it
it's in georg's
Hometown so that was a great opportunity
for Dave to come and meet with us again
and just talk to us right yeah and then
that Monday when he gets back he's
walked out of the geospatial
intelligence agency or nro depending on
which one you want to identify him with
he's he's out man and they did some
[__] on him like time card like out
of out of 12,000 billable hours maybe
there's like 30 hours somewhere where
you didn't do it right they were doing
anything they could to [__] with this
guy so that was our first like heads up
oh dude how this guy gets treated is
going to dictate everybody else that has
come to us in private saying I I I think
this is illegal what I'm doing right
among the complaints they issued to try
to take away his security clearance was
that he had mental health issues yeah so
he was suspended for a couple of months
they did a background investigation of
his allegations the allegations that
have been made against him and they
cleared him reinstated him reinstated
his security clearance he stayed on the
job for a couple more months and then
retired because he sees the handwriting
on the wall and he left and that's when
he he started um plotting the next
chapter and now we're seeing the
backlash process firing up once again
after he testifies in front of Congress
in that hearing and offers to tell them
more in a classified setting and spill
all the beans uh they they got to find a
media guy to go after them this article
in The Intercept yes The Intercept did a
smash piece by the way we already knew
all about Dave gr's P PTSD M and at the
time his best friend one of his dear
friends just t got off the phone with
him blew his own brains out right so he
was like drinking he was in a bad place
first day day one I talked to him I said
what dirt are they going to pull up on
you if if what you're telling me is true
they're going to get some dirt and he
goes look man I had PTSD I dealt with it
I survived it nothing horrible happened
but you know he told us day one man that
intercept thing was some [__] they
they come in and they they try to
discredit what he said because of his
PTSD [__] and the thing is that happened
to Lazar like if you believe or don't
believe don't care that did happen to
Lazar too where people try to discredit
his character to try to minimize what
he's telling you so we saw that with
Dave and that was only the visible stuff
I'm telling you things behind the scenes
that have been done to Dave and his
family it's disgusting like not even
just like pull your clearance kind of
[__] like there are people that don't
want him he's an embarrassment you know
to the Department of Defense if what
he's saying he's coming out of school
and he's saying I saw some BS like they
don't want that so we are in a push back
phase they they not only the
intelligence community and Military
folks tipped off a reporter and said go
look for this and they found some police
records of where he was drinking too
much and was suicidal uh and and that
was adjudicated uh it was looked at the
dep Department of Defense his his
employers looked into it he'd gone
through treatment he got past it he was
a better person person a stronger person
for it but they leaked that information
to just be SMG his character and now we
see additional uh push back in Congress
so this committee that held this hearing
into UFO UAP matters uh was a
subcommittee on National Security of the
oversight committee the larger committee
since that hearing happened uh the
chairman of the house intelligence
committee got together with the chairman
of the oversight committee and decided
no more UFO hearings in the house enough
of that [__] we're not doing that
anymore because in their words it could
be an embarrassment to the Department of
Defense you're damn right it would be an
embarrassment for what's going to come
out I mean it was a big success you know
to have this this publicly done it's the
first time in history that we have
direct Witnesses like two pilots and
then a
whistleblower it was the first time in
history we we fought for every
millimeter of that territory to get that
to happen it was not received well by
the intelligence Community you know they
did not like that that happened and
that's pretty telling to
me that we should do it
again